proving to the universe every day that
i'm never going to let it happen again
by putting on this uniform and waiting
on the rich and famous
in between my gifts it's got to be the
worst it actually wasn't i actually
found it fascinating because again it's
like it it helped me get less
intimidated by the famous because
obviously when you're working on set
with people sometimes it's like holy
[ __ ]
have you have you been like that with
wrong yeah i mean i remember even on the
office when timothy oliphant uh
was um recurring on our show and i had
oh yeah you had a [ __ ] i had a big
thing with a big scene with him and i
was like
big thing with him that sounds wrong
that's wrong
i was too and i was like i was like just
go you got to just jump jump jump jump
jump we're just doing this but i had
watched ted wood and i was like you know
and he's a really good looking guy
whatever
but you didn't get you got in a little
intimidated yes yeah really did he know
it because i bet he was intimidated by
you well also here's the second city
well it was also one of his first days
on the show maybe he was just
intimidated being on the show i don't
know if it was me personally but i'm
sure you didn't google me before but um
which is fine uh i bet he did i don't
know
i don't know let's ask him timothy come
on out
did you imagine i brought timothy just
for that thank god i didn't say anything
just for that more intimidating than
what i just said oh my god but you know
stuff like so yeah i mean everyone you
know and kathy bates was on the show and
i was like
i know do you say something to her what
do you say what you do
uh you get star struck and do you say
can i have your autograph do you do
things like that no no no no no no no no
we're we're working together you know
but you also have to find the common
ground and like you know
and you have to sort of take their
temperature i mean i really she had a
lot to do because she had all she did
was like monologues at first because she
was the the big boss that would come in
so she had these big speeches so it
wasn't about having like short little
clippy conversations with her in between
takes she had a lot in her head was she
nervous she was i could tell she was
yeah yeah but did she do well she she
was great i mean she's amazing but this
is the thing she really gives a [ __ ] so
that's why she's an a and that's why she
has an academy award like she takes
everything she does super strong yeah
and you're thinking how is she nervous
doesn't it make you feel better when you
see big stars nervous totally kind of
gives you a little confidence a little
bit yeah like hey
that person's a human being absolutely
and everybody has their process and you
know obviously when you're joining a
cast that already exists it's it's got
it's so weird we had a much more
friendly set than most shows like i've
i've been guest started some shows where
i'm like no thank you like if i
you know and it's always weird when it's
an offer it's like i don't even ask to
be here and this is weird you know what
am i doing here right
it's like thanks for nothing universe
what the hell it's like i was just
minding my own business and now i'm in
this [ __ ] show well it's because
you're like the henry winkler of women
you are the kindest people want to work
with you yeah
well you know what it is people that's
the highest compliment it is because if
you know henry
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast